welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session
perspectives on neuropsychiatric
disorders it is my pleasure to introduce
to you dr. Thiago Maia dr. Maia is an
associate professor at the Faculty of
Medicine at the University of Lisbon a
researcher at the Institute for
molecular medicine in Lisbon and a
member of the Coordinating Council of
the mind we're in college of the
University of Lisbon for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of the
screen dr. Maya's talk today will be
using computational psychiatry to
develop a Rigger's and interpretive
understanding of psychiatric disorders
my name is dr. Rushton akashi-kun chair
of neuroscience 2019 and I will be your
moderator for this talk we are delighted
to bring you this educational web
seminar presented by lab foods before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to questions following the
presentation the presentation is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab at the top right corner of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without any further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Thiago Maia dr. aya
thank you well thank you very much for
the introduction so I'm really excited
to be able to talk to you today about
this idea of using computational
psychiatry to develop rigorous and
integrative understanding of psychiatric
disease so I structured my talking first
three or four slides I'm just going to
give you a very very big picture of why
we think computational psychiatry is a
good idea and why it's important to
develop these rigors and integrity of
understanding why we need that integrity
kind of approach and then I'll
illustrate that with a specific
application in this case the Tourette
syndrome in which I think we've been
able to develop a fairly comprehensive
understanding of a lot of things that
are going on
threaten him by using these
computational models as a theoretical
framework trust in a liar way in then
we'll move on to the specifics and I
always like to start with this quote
from any pankaja who was a famous
mathematician and philosopher of science
french mathematician and fellow for
science they said science is built up of
facts as a house is built up of stones
but an accumulation of facts is no more
science than a heap of stones is a house
and I always like to show this because I
think it's something that we really need
to pay attention to very often I feel
that we're learning more and more facts
and no there is not as much of a house
building as I think there should be not
as much as trying to put all of those
together in a way that makes sense in in
a cohesive form and so when I look at
science I often look at this kind of
house as opposed to a well structured
house so this is you can tell some
things here that are we can tell there's
some trees out there you can tell
there's maybe you tell bits and pieces
some of them in some parts of the story
seem to go here together but then a lot
of the things really are not related
they're bits and pieces and a lot of my
focus in the last couple of years has
been trying to see can we move beyond
these bits and pieces to move into
disintegrative accounts and part of the
problem so I like to show this this
slide which is from Leonardo da Vinci is
you probably know and it's really
because he's studying the the
proportions of mathematical proportions
between different things the length of
the arms is equal to the heights and
then this is one tenth of there and so
on and so he's trying to look at all of
these proportions in the human body and
what we do in science is actually we
take something and we split it into many
many different little pieces and so we
end up studying these little pieces very
often and then we lose the perspective
of the the global thing and so what I've
been trying to do is can we put together
the pieces again so that we can actually
see the whole and can we make an
integrated sorry from the whole and of
course you don't necessarily need
computational approaches so if you saw
the previous talk by Tony grace it's a
very very nice example of how he has
been able to provide the value he's if
account of a very large number of things
without the the computational
mathematical approach but I like to add
the mathematics to it just because like
Galileo said philosophy or in this case
philosophy at the time nature is written
in that great book which is ever before
our eyes
I mean the universe but we cannot
understand it if we do not first learn
the language in which it is written the
book is written in mathematical language
without which one wonders in fine
through dark so the idea is can we bring
mathematics to bear on problems in
psychiatry to avoid wandering in vain
through this to our clients that has led
us to not make as much progress as we
would have liked given the resources
that we've allocated and so
computational psychiatry when I say
computational really I mean mathematical
and its computational rather than just
mathematical because usually the
mathematics that we use are not solved
in closed form solutions it so you need
simulations and that's where the
computational comes along but it's
essentially the same thing and there's
two types of big approaches to
computational psychiatry there are some
of the sticker fairly distinct in
principle one is you can use
computational psychiatry to do fancy
data analysis so machine learning I call
this statistics 2.0 and this is
data-driven with big data typically it's
largely a theoretical often um
completely ignore even any hypotheses or
anything like that and you just deriving
patterns out of the data and it's
promising it has started to yield very
interesting results I like it but I tend
to feel that it throws away the baby
with the bathwater
in the sense that we've been studying
mechanisms and so on for so many decades
now and then often this is just
completely ignores all of that and just
girls from the data and so the other
face of competition
character that I will be focusing on
today is using these computational
models to develop theories of what is
actually going on and this is sort of
the standard in physics it was the
standard since the beginning of physics
so Newton started by developing calculus
to account for at the same time that he
was developing physics and two things
were always very intertwined in biology
more generally in psychiatry in
particular there has not been the case
but I think the time is right we're just
a couple of years late but at the time
is ripe to bring those things together
there's also the possibility of
combining these two approaches the
theory development and the machine
learning and this has certain advantages
I'll be happy to discuss if you want to
ask some questions about that but for
today I really just want to focus on the
theory development part of the story so
there was sort of my very broad
introduction to why computational
psychiatry why now why might we want to
be doing this of course it probably
sounds a little vague and it was a
little fight and and we need to put some
meat on to these bones and so we'll do
that by trying to see if we can use this
to start to make sense of what is going
on in given this or in this case in
Tourette syndrome and particularly the
role of dopamine in Tourette's
so threatenin as you probably know is a
disorder characterized mostly by ticks
so this can be more vocal so these are
repetitive movements such as effective
eye blinking or shoulder shrugging or
cuffing in your throat
and this is the visible side of the
disorder things that serve Diagnostics
I'm sorry but most patients also
required that they have premonitory
urges and these are things that they
these are feelings that they have that
uncomfortable sensations they sort of
compel them to do the things because it
takes alleviate those permanent areas
and so patients with Tourette's will
often tell you that they're doing that
it's a really involuntary actions used
to be thought but it's a semi voluntary
so they you would rather not do the tea
but they have the premonitory urge and
so they have the feeling that they have
to do the take to alleviate that very
disturbing
urghhh and I've been dressing both
phases of dressing cycling the motor
component and then I'll address the
premonitory urges later on and so what
we know about dopamine urging
disturbances in Tourette's and I've been
covering a lot of ground so for each
section I'll give you a little bit
summary to capture what goes on next
section and the summary huge that my
interpretation of the day is that
Tourette syndrome probably involves
dopaminergic hyper and eventually there
is too many dopamine terminals
particularly in distract and so what
what's the evidence for that she's from
the table from me and from a reviewer
just published last year in which we
reviewed the patent spec studies of the
dopamine system in Tourette's and we
have here the several markers of the
dopamine system on the left are the ones
that have been studied and then each
little box is a study and green studies
means that it was shown and those
studies showed an increase in Tourette's
relative to controls and yellow studies
showed no difference and the single red
study shows any increase in controls
relative to Tourette's and it's serve
and not likely and so if you just
eyeball this table you see that there's
about as much green as there is yellow
so there's about it as many positive
studies as there are none studies now
the thing with this is that this should
not be taking a symmetric because the
the way did the evidence to reach a
significant result is it's much harder
to reach a significant result than to
reach a null result especially with the
really really tiny samples that have
been using most of these that so many of
these studies have had around ten
subjects so a new result with ten
subjects can very well just be an
underpowered
study and most likely it is because this
studies really were all very small not
only were they small they often had
nasty confounds the typical one is
there's more patients more male patients
than in the control group
some are males in the patients in
control group because threats tends to
occur more in males and why is there a
bomb because we know that for example
females actually have a higher and
higher that
is higher densities of the dopamine
transport so if you're putting more
females in the control group and you
don't find the difference it might just
be because there's more females in the
control group and that might be sort of
washing out the fact that it would
otherwise see and so overall although
the evidence actually the quality of the
heiress is extremely poor the studies
are very small so there's lots of
confounds and the quality of the
emphasis is extremely important but it
is what it is and insofar as we can take
this evidence and I I really would urge
no funding agencies and so on to fund
more of these studies and larger scale
studies because for example in
schizophrenia field is so much further
ahead in terms of understanding all of
these things there's been so much more
investment in in all of the studies and
here the unfortunately there isn't but
insofar as what we can tell and based on
this idea that it's harder to get a
positive result in a null result it
seems that the evidence would suggest
that there is a need an increase in
these dopamine markers these various
dopamine markers interacts and then the
that ties well with the effects of
medication and so on as we'll see
further in a little bit and then the
question is well okay so how do you
interpret this and there's typically
what happens people for example there's
a very nice review of the dopamine
services in threats and it's as if
there's four main hypotheses but often
each hypothesis like it refers to just a
single set of studies and so people find
something else and they say okay so this
is a new hypothesis and again I like to
think of the integrative approach how
can you explain everything as simply as
possible of course nothing no simpler
but as simply as possible and if you
think about all of those findings they
all can emerge out of the simple fact
that if there is too much dopamine
innovation there is too many
dopamine terminals then you would
actually see all of those funds you
would see an increase in the dopamine
transporter because there's more
terminals there you'd see an increase in
synthesis again they're smart terminals
there you'd see in increasing the
physical irma know I mean
Parker - I'll show you what this is in a
moment but this is something that is
also in the presynaptic terminals and of
course you would see an increase in
phenomena induced dopamine release which
is another finding in threads and so the
dopamine hyper innervation give you an
explanation for all of those findings
all of the molecular imaging findings
anyways we will see it also interacts
with a lot of other findings as well so
this is where the integrity and it comes
in and so just to together an idea of
this I'm schematically showing here
three dopamine terminals and here that
they all the same and there is the
dopamine transporter is present in the
terminal Turkish dopamine release by the
terminal the female 2 is a transporter
that could dopamine into the vesicles
and then you also have the citizen so
these are the four things that are being
measured in the back inspect studies and
if you have more dopamine terminals then
you're going to have more of all of
these things of course when we're doing
pairing spec we don't know we mention
things that are very very cross level
and so there's alternative
interpretations and I won't be like
those other thing I'll mention one that
is more popular but you could think that
there's other things going on and one
hypothesis that has been quite popular
he said instead of the dopamine
transporter which is really the most
commonly replicated study because also
that's where there's more studies to a
large extent instead of the increase in
dopamine transporter meaning that
there's more terminals it might mean
that there's more dopamine transporter
per terminal so if there was the case
the idea and the story is that there's a
decrease then in extracellular that
causes a decrease in extracellular
dopamine and you could imagine that
there would be there would lead to some
of the other fungi I want to label the
details of that although this is
published you can you can look at the
details but it would explain the
increase in the v-max - but there's a
bigger problem with this idea
and then I'll mention this in slider to
you could still think that it would be
the increasing since that would be
problematic and explain perhaps some of
the other findings but not all of them
but the the hypothesis of the increased
dopamine hyper innovation really ends up
in the most parsimonious because it
explains all of this and it really
explained a lot of other findings so so
if the tourettes does involve dopamine
hyper innovation then this would be the
first hyper dopaminergic to men too much
dopamine and you would have in principle
both too much tonic dopamine and this is
dopamine that's hanging around there if
you if you saw Tony Bryce's talk you
know this very well has worked on this
idea of tonic in physical and also more
physic document which is the dopamine
that is release relevant in relation to
stimuli and that occurs did the finding
of dopamine neurons here occurs and the
hundreds of milliseconds as where as the
tonic dopamine is something that is much
more stable over time now if that's the
case if he needs to achieve of dopamine
hyper innervation medication should
decrease in if that leads to increased
tonic and physic dopamine then
medication should decrease tonic and/or
phasic dopamine transmission to be
effective and indeed I'll show you that
that's exactly what they do they
decrease one or the other or both and
then and this is what I will use
computational methods to then argue the
increased phasic dopamine is this is the
hypose increase pacific dopamine is
going to promote the learning of things
whereas the increased stomach dopamine
using to promote the expression of tics
and again to this distinction a little
bit so the idea that tics are learned
behaviors in particular and being to
argue that they learned motor habits
they learned abnormally because of the
increased dopamine that's and the
increases phasic firing of document and
then
the tonic dopamine is going to increase
all your general motor activity and the
expression of these learned behaviors
and we'll see that in more detail
further one now I wanted to mention in
more detail one of the prior hypothesis
just to explain why it's not quite that
procedure ism is not so wise and the
spire hypothesis was based on the idea
that the increase that the increase
dopamine transporter that you see in pet
actually means too much dopamine per
terminal and if it means too much
dopamine per terminal then dopamine is
going then then is going to react take
too much dopamine there really to love
tonic dopamine as opposed to high as I'm
suggesting and deadly to talk low tonic
dopamine and then because he didn't have
as much tonic dopamine the auto
receptors for dopamine would be less
less occupied and so that would lead to
an increase in physics so the
traditional idea if you look up tonic
phasic hypothesis of tres the
traditional idea is that the tonic
Dohenys decrease and facing increased
rather than both thing increasing as I'm
suggesting and I want to deconstruct a
little bit that idea to explain why I
think that's that's unlikely so again
the received reasons and reticles
decrease tonic up
so you all right the problems as I said
this is based on the idea that there is
too much dopamine pearl too much that
per terminal and so there's too much
Realty well if that was the case then
how do you best treat dress well of
course you just thought the dopamine
transporting from the problems that
there's too much of it
you just block it and that's what
simulants do but of course stimulants
are not a first line of treatment for
drugs in fact there's been a long
discussion about whether they make it
worse rather than better
and there's several meta-analysis it
story is quite complicated but for sure
it's not an effective treatment for
threats you don't go to the your doctor
say I have threatened and they give you
some money to trade threats for sure
that already should suggest that that's
not a good idea and another problem with
their idea is it was based on early
findings that haloperidol actually
increased homophony leak acid which is
dopamine metabolites in servo spinal
fluid and so and this was occurring at
the same time as it was improving
threads and so people interpreting this
to mean that haloperidol instead of
actually blocking dopamine transmission
which is what really does that this was
somehow increasing dopamine the problem
with that is that there's lots of
evidence that haloperidol actually
decreases funny dopamine in the stratum
it does not increase and there's other
medications such as amphetamine in which
the effectively sings Triton's the
opposite of the effect that you see in
CSF so really the CSF is not a good
measure the permanencia separately is
not a good measure of documents right
and yet another problem with the TS
involves the low tonic document is
opposed to high tonic dopamine is that
d2 receptors which is where all of the
entire psychotics which are one of the
main treatments for Tourette's packed d2
receptors are more sensitive to tonic
dopamine as opposed to face it dopamine
or the particularly sensitive to the
deliver so they're sensitive to both but
because they have their high affinity
they actually if you block the two
receptors they were sensitive to tonic
dopamine you decreasing the effect of
time well there will be a terrible idea
PS already involved reduction and
dopamine to be blocking those receptors
that are already sensitive stop needs
just imagine the problem worse there was
the case in you should only be a of the
tree yes by using something like a copy
by mutuality one receptor which has
lower sensitivity to dopamine a lower
affinity to dopamine and therefore is
mostly activated by the face so for this
reason in fact other reasons I don't
think the idea that yes involves low
tonic
is in fact this idea of the the reverse
relation between tonic and physical
organic and high phasic was originally
during sort of suggested by Tommy grace
the previous speaker first his opinion
then it was adapted for for Christ but
if you her on this prior talk you also
know that okay now he's suggesting that
the more don't nerves are fine tonic
fine the more they can in fire
physically and so in fact the
relationship anything might be positive
between the tonic and the physic fine
okay so so that part was to try to see
what we know about the molecular imaging
of dopamine system in Tourette's and we
came into the conclusion that it seems
that it suggests that there's increased
innovation of interest of American
aggression in stress now how does that
relate to the pharmacology of stress
well it turns out that all medications
used to treat attracts actually reduced
dopamine transmission and so this slide
here it's a little bit busy but it shows
all of the main medications that are
used to treat
Tourette's and it shows that they
actually all reduce dopamine
transmission in one way or another so in
the interests of time in because this is
poss-eye
I won't go through every single little
step here but I will highlight a couple
that are perhaps a little bit less
intuitive and that so the very very
typical one and the intuitive one is the
two antagonists most antipsychotics to
them they are blocking the post synaptic
d2 receptors also the presynaptic but
they does that there is they block a lot
the postsynaptic receptors and that is
reducing the transmission of them so
that's a very very intuitive case now
and pleasantly difficult and more
interesting and also shows how much you
need to look into the
this is the case of low doses of
dopamine agonists so dopamine agonists
at low doses actually improved
Tourette's and so you might think that
this is a counter to having too much
dopamine why would you give a dopamine
agonist and it would work well because
at low doses dopamine agonists actually
work mostly on presynaptic receptors
outer receptors and thereby the release
of dopamine so in case B here low doses
of fertile it has been shown between
proof threats and the way it does that
is it acts more on this low dose he
likes Martin the presynaptic at the
presynaptic level and again that then
has a series of mechanisms that will
lead to a reduction in the release of
dopamine in addition to in the synthesis
of dopamine the firing of the neurons
and even it up regulates the dopamine
transporter itself now changing the
story of the dopamine agonists love
those bananas cousin people said okay
let's try another one
especially because partly test them some
worrisome side effects and they tried
here if you look in see they tried low
dose of em impacts all and it actually
did not work and so people sort of
abandoned this but I can take it so
erroneously because if you look at the
details with chronic use lot of those of
pramipexole stopped having much of an
effect on the d2 auto receptor which is
the one that helps to down regulate all
of the dopamine activity and they have
they continue to have an effect on the
d3 outer receptor which does not do that
in fact it seems to do the opposite and
so we have suggestions about which which
other dopamine agonist should be tried
that have a better profile here or in
terms of direction on the d2 s versus
the d3
auto receptor and I think it's a good
example of we really need to look at the
details and try to understand why one
thing works
one doesn't to them be able to make
progress and so the other the only other
thing that I wanted to say is not to
spend too much time on this slide I'll
just seal on that case it should not be
surprising that Lodo's from Excel does
not help with threats because if you in
fact it's a treatment for Parkinson's
slow those pramipexole is a treatment
for Parkinson's disease and so that just
goes show that it should if anything be
having an effect on to increasing
dopamine which is not what you want for
dress low dose perkily is not a
treatment for Parkinson's in fact it
makes Parkinson's worse and so it is
still all very consistent with the idea
that there's too much dopamine in trains
just before before leaving this slide I
wanted to mention here the mechanism
here II which is in the u.s. in
particular North American the first line
of Britain for three threads typically
is offered to an offer to a agonists
it's not because they have a bigger
effect size it's because because they
don't antipsychotics I'll be going but
it's because their side effect profile
is more beneficial but as it turns out
alpha - whenever alpha to a particular
acnes decrease dopamine release as well
and so again this is actually related to
and can be related to the token occur
okay so there was so we saw first the
part of the molecular imaging studies
the hyper innovation to explain a lot of
the all of the findings in any also
explains why all of the medications that
are used to treat traits reduce dopamine
transmission now what we know about the
pathophysiology of Tourette's and here
what we know is that threat involves
disturbances in the motor loop through
the basal cane not only the motor look
there's also a big amount of sensory
areas and that will come up for
premonitory urge us later in the talk
but for now I'm focusing on on the motor
part so and certainly the motor loop has
been very strong okay so this is just
from a
two years ago now and what it shows is
it shows in here some structural
abnormalities in Tourette syndrome and
um served the right of the but you have
the murder loop so you have the motor
cortical motor areas m1 supplementary
motor area see what more area then you
have to look through the basal ganglia
the potatoman
go up spirals and thalamus here you have
the dopamine regions on the lower left
the VTA in the S&C and then on the top
left you have some other sensory regions
endings which are also involved and so
the way this is color-coded is that if
it's green it means that there's a
reduction in cortical thickness and if
you notice there's basically all almost
all of these regions that I mentioned
have reduced cortical thickness in in
patients with yes and reduced structural
connectivity between cortical regions
and the striatum those are the green
arrows and then so cortically actually
you see the opposite effect the the
yellows mean an increase and you
actually have an opposite effect you
have an increase in volumes in the
putamen in the thumbs and also in
regions consistent with the dopaminergic
regions so the reason for this
discrepancy the thinning in one case and
the thick thickness or thickening in the
thinning in the cortical and the thin
thickness in the subcortical and this is
interesting and it leaves the details
about that
but for now suffice excited all of these
regions are involved and these are the
regions from the murder the basically
the somatosensory edges functional
studies show exactly the same thing so
this is just showing and all of those
regions are hyperactive in Tourette's or
hyperactive at rest or they acted before
Nations T and in a way that's related to
ticks and so on so really this structure
is very very this
Lupe's well-known to be evil and this is
just from study and exempt from stuff
that I was involved in fuse recommends
to a postdoc at Columbia and in the type
of Pearson and where we also showed
hyperactivity in Merlot in TS in all of
those regions that I was mentioning
supplementary motor area primary motor
cortex retirement thousands and so on we
also a functional connectivity between
regions in the motor loop in tracks and
this is a very busy slide because the
arrows represent all the connections
between those regions but the arrows in
orange represent an increase in
functional connectivity and I wanted to
highlight here the dopamine the increase
in functional connectivity from dopamine
regions to the striatum as one of the
things that we found which is quite
interesting and again consistent with
their idea of the hyper innervation of
the stratum by dopamine terminals okay
so we now know that the more loop is
involved in Tourette's but what does it
do and why would it be fault interest
well to some extent you would expect it
to be involved in threads because it's a
motor disorder in the season
these are motor structures so some
examples it's perhaps a no-brainer but
it's not so much because it's
interesting that the whole loop
including the basal ganglia circuitry is
involved and then I'm now when I'm moved
to the pathophysiology I sort of talked
a little bit about dopamine but I didn't
talk about how it ties with everything
else and now we'll see how it ties how
these things that use pathophysiological
findings tie back to the idea of the
hyper Eurasian and so that comes because
the more loop is involved in learning
and executing motor habits and the way
learns in the way plunge them is should
open and so if there's too much dopamine
you this will lead to too much habit
learning and the tics will be decipher
and exaggerated perhaps and then if you
too much dopamine there will also lead
to too much happy execution and that
part I will explain with the
computational model so I unprepared I
left the computational heart till the
end because the emphasis is on building
an integrative approach and the
competition part is to the extent that
it helps to do that and as you'll see it
will be very helpful okay so there's a
lot of evidence that the murder loop is
involved in hanok learning in the
execution I'll just mention one of our
own studies for assertive purposes but
there's certainly many understands about
this and here we conducted the study in
which people had to learn a and learning
in habit a habit is a stimulus response
Association so it's something that you
it's a responsibility to perform in a
given situation automatically no longer
because you're wanting a certain goal
and you can model this using a thing
called cue learning which in essence you
can think of these Q values that this
comes from the machine learn English as
the strength of the association between
the stimulus s and the response are or
because in machine learning people
usually use a for action
q si is like the strength of the
association between stimulus and
response like SR from the Thorndike
classical ideas about stimulus response
xx and so what we found is that we look
at the areas whose activity correlated
with the strength of the habit and to
infer the strength of the habit in the
person's brain used thing called model
by fMRI which makes these computational
models and that square things start to
get and from professional and we looked
at because of course the strength of a
having - something that you have to
infer from behavior you cannot do from
behavior then you can look at the neural
correlates of that inference strength
that's what we do here and so we found
that e in the steriliser of the time and
also in differential
right and we found a correlation with
the strength of the hand but we think
the action is really the post era life
or patella and not in the pentose cycle
because we have people who in the study
who were able to learn the habit and
others who are not able to learn that
and what we Singlish them was that the
people who learned the habit actually
engage that region of the posterior
lateral thing and the putamen I should
know is a region that has been very
involved in threats and so this is where
you're starting to learn whatever habits
and this is where then the things would
be learned now what does this have to do
with dopamine well what it has to do
with dopamine the habits are learning
based on the finding of the faceook
finding of the commoners so this is a
long-standing idea from computational
models so if you have your sensory car
this is representing the state or
situation that would be your s and then
in the containment you would have your
actions your potential actions action
one actually two series of actions then
of course the timing receives very
strong innovational from dopamine now if
you're in a given state let's say a1 you
perform a given action let's say action
one
oh and just before I say that so so the
idea is going to be so we know from the
work of Wolfram Schultz as dopamine
neurons represent a thing called the
prediction error and yeah I didn't is
that we found in the putamen these Q
values so they're not really the actions
of just but the value of direction which
in turn can be interpreted as the
strength of the Association from the
signals to the action so and we know
from the machine learning literature
that the way you learn these Q values is
by using the prediction in or so a Q
value without getting into the technical
details a Q value is learned through
this prediction which is signaled by the
so it makes a lot of sense that you have
Q values entertainment and you have
prediction areas signaled by document
that document
strongly to detainment because that's
where you you want to be using it to
learn the key events and so that part
makes a lot of sense and so what's the
IDS again let's say you're in state one
you perform action one and then that
leads to something good in general this
would be if it leads to something good
then you will get a fine of your
dopamine neurons and because of that
fine through that will have an effect on
particles trying to plasticity there
there will strengthen the association
between that state and direction and so
now next time you'll be more likely to
perform again direction when you're in
that state notice though that if the
dopamine neurons fire when they should
have fired whatever action you were
performing actually got strength and so
if this was some think you were
performing some action then you had this
big burst in dopamine earned in Wi on
frying that you shouldn't have gotten or
this big dopamine release in the
striatum and you just strengthened
something that you should not have
strengthened and that would be two
mechanisms and particular now if this is
in the - if there is change in
functional connectivity we should be
able to see a change in functional
connectivity between sensory regions and
the time - people learn and indeed we
did find that we did we found this is a
busy slide it shows an increase in
yellow you see the increase in
functional connectivity between those
regions and the put a man in proportion
to that Cavell in proportion to the
strength of the Hat and what you see
that those sensory and motor regions are
actually increasing their connectivity
to the putamen as people learn the habit
just as has been long hypothesized by
computational models and this actually
occurred in people who learn the habit
but not in people who did not learn that
now changing it we also found a set of
regions where disconnecting from there
there's a very very interesting story
for them
why you
getting there and how it's consistent
with a set of things but in Joseph's
time I know I'll cross over there okay
so what have you just seen well we saw
from pathophysiology section that the
motor loop is involved in TLC threads we
just saw now that those same regions in
particular central thing the striatum
and feminine
are involving habits and so this leads
me to the hypothesis that tics may be
exaggerated maladaptive motor habits but
ok why aren't they there and then this
is where the dopamine account comes in
because habit learning and execution are
modulated by dopamine I already started
to mention that I mentioned in more
detail computationally next and if
that's the case then the hyper
dopaminergic in TS might be what
underlies the successive habit learning
in the execution that produces tics and
in turn produces those structural
abnormalities in those regions of the
more loop inside that we discuss ok so
let's talk a little bit in more detail
about the computational rules of
dopamine first in general because we
always need to have a model of function
before you have massage and then the
implications for Tourette's
and as I mentioned before the ideas of
increased physical coming because of the
dopamine hyperinflation promotes thick
learning whereas increased tonic
dopamine
also because of dopamine - evasion
promotes seek execution and this
distinction between learning and
execution will actually have
implications for example for treatment
because you might be as a preview you
might be modulating the execution of
things inhibiting the execution of
things but not really causing their
unlearning which is what in pretty so
this is a very important distinction
so dopamine has served two basic roles
and simplistic somewhat simplistic way
but a reasonably accurate face it
dopamine is used for enforcing planning
for learning things and we saw how
tonic dopamine is used for configuring
action or causing you to perform more
actions just a per unit time and
especially amplifying the learned
actions and this is why increased on a
document would lead to more Martok's
Matic expression I cross over this
because it's getting into the details of
the computation and I then I won't have
time to get into a lot of details but
let me just jump right into this to say
so previously I talked about the
strengthening of the cortical straddle
synapses from cortex to describe them as
a mechanism for learning but it turns
out and that he would strengthen those
when you had a positive prediction
that's how you would learn habit but it
turns out in the brainy things are a
little bit more complicated because
instead of having just one system to
learn these stimulus-response
associations you have to opponent
systems and this is has been very nicely
sadly has been very nicely developed by
Michael Frank and Margaret more recently
with n callings that they've laid up
missing very very nice coherent way and
the idea is that but this also goes back
many many years the idea of the direct
versus indirect pathway as this opponent
pathways through the basal thing and so
the opponent actors are the direct
pathway which is represented here in
green on the left and the indirect
pathway which is represented in red on
the right and Michael and I mean that
there's like to call the direct pathway
the go halfway and G represents go and
the indirect pathway you know go because
the direct path is going to see action
execution so it's go and the indirect is
going to inhibit action execution it's
no-go and and really the tendency to
perform an action is going to result
from a subtraction of two passes but so
yeah then is how does
faceook dopamine lead to learning well
so if you have yeah is it
affects differentially plasticity in the
two pathways and so if you have a
bursting dopamine nervous you can
characterize this mathematically but if
you have a person dopamine notice what
happens what happens is that the go path
for it on the left is getting thicker
because that's how you cause of the
effect on d1 receptors you're
strengthening their Association and the
effect on the right pathway if anything
is actually getting weaker and so here
you'll have more go for direction you
just learned to perform that action and
you're going to have a very tense
now what about dopamine tonic dopamine
has an effect named during the choice
just see how I'm thinking for time here
so tonic has an effect during choice and
this effect it should be using from the
effect unlearn and in fact during choice
this is fairly busy slide the idea
dopamine is going to modulate the
excitability of God and no go medium
spiny neurons in the striatum
differentiate and magic because panic
dopamine he's going to affect mostly the
indirect pathway in the neural pathway
because d2 receptors have higher if
anything so far the low levels of tonic
documenter are present the d2 receptor
seem to be the one that's most affect
the d1 welcome to be less effect and as
I said in he and really the tendency to
perform the action is going to be the
subtraction of these two tendencies and
then you can normalize this in terms of
what happens to other actions but so
yeah even if you have more dopamine and
I run this this little animation again
if you have more dopamine notice what
happens what happens is that the mortal
community to inhibit the no-go pathway
inhibiting the noble nerves and so
you're going to have much less of the
knuckle she have more go and less no-go
you're going to have more tendency to
perform the actions in particularly
actions for which you have learned the
habit of performing them that is
decidedly actions in which those
synapses the cortical strike of synapses
are strong and so I know that this is a
little faster you just give you a
general idea the sizes are also
published that can look up the
references there but so the idea then is
that the tonic dopamine will decrease
your logo and make you more likely to
perform the go
that is to say to perform a tic so based
on this idea of the function of the
pathways you can actually derive the
whole structure of the basal ganglia why
it is the way it is and how it works out
but I go through that in interest of
time and I also skip this part here but
so going back now to the beginning
yeah the TS involves dopamine - question
remember these we're all driving with
deriving everything from very simple
principles then if he involves dopamine
hyper innovation it increases fuzzy and
tiny dopamine and the phasic dopamine is
evolving the TIC learning those bursts
and tonic the community expression
overall motor hyperactivity so let me
now try to just give an illustration for
how this would work in TS and I've
simplified things very here to make easy
so I'm representing here just a single
state or situation I'm representing the
tick and an alternative action a and I'm
representing the direct pathway in a
very simplistic way just by showing the
striatum and and the effect of that
little dimply hands on your cortex and
so that's in green is the direct or go
pathway and in red is to interact or
knockout matter and what happens is that
in unmedicated stating Tourette's
because you have learned because of
those evarin phrasing responses
notice that the synapse formed
according to the striking for the tea is
already very thick so you've learned the
tip by this management habit learn due
to the abnormal finding of the
prominence now in addition to that
notice what happens the noble structures
are fairly inhibited the activity there
is fairly inhibited why because you have
a lot of fun dopamine and that's hitting
the d2 receptors that's inhibiting the
no-go pathway and so you have a lot of
go and very little no-go and so you have
a great tendency to perform the tick
here in the motor cortex the tea it's
like this big box because you have the
tendency to perform now notice what
happens in when you give it an
anti-psychotic acutely now we're going
to consider what happens with an acute
antipsychotic those if it would be one
that was already defective so what them
do is it would it would plug the d2
receptors in the normal pathway okay and
by blocking those d2 receptors in the
neural pathway those nerves those MSN's
are going to be able to be more active
and so they're now more active and
they're able to perform them to then
give more no go to the teeth and because
do you can see the permanently is also
difference between the going no-go
there will actually reduce the tendency
to perform lytic now if of course it
might also the distance it from other
actions as well and that would be
involved in the in the side-effects but
notice that here entice iconic you're
just increasing the expression of the
tea you didn't affect the learning you
didn't affect the plasticity to affect
the learning to actually have an effect
on
unlearning you need to affect the
plasticity and indeed with chronic
antipsychotic use their settings that
you will affect the ICC so with ronique
antipsychotics what you would have then
is that you'd actually get a
strengthening of the cortical stripe of
synapses for the no-go and so you're
actually now performing unlearning
which on top of the effect on expression
will lead to even
for Datak and therefore an even greater
ability to inhibit the tick so this
would be why you get a continued
improvement in trends with chronic use
as opposed to just acute now it's
finishing and I don't have time to gain
the dynamics of what happens and when
you remove antipsychotics and so on
it's quite interesting that often
patients won't immediately get back to
having the full the full extent of the
ticks they had before but they sorry
enquire them which is a very real
learning of the Texan that is question
which has been in some details about
this so I have I don't have a lot of
time like this because I don't know me
some time for questions but I didn't
want to now get back to premonitory
because for now we've talked a lot about
how from the dopamine hyper innervation
you get all of the things that come so
far
really until what I've mentioned here
but now what about the premonitory urges
and really pramana Terriers are those
sensations that patients have and a
summary of what the section is about and
the neuro substances of this seems to
involve the somatosensory cortices the
insula which we think is sort of a point
of intersection between somatosensory
and the motor and perhaps the motor
cortices and how does this relate to
dopamine well it relates to dopamine in
the sense that we premonitory urge is an
aversive sensation so it's something
that patients don't like the idea that
we need terminate something that is bad
they're actually elicits a positive
prediction error so mathematically you
go from a state in which something is
bad from a negative state to a state
which is you and the prediction and
mathematically is the difference between
what you got - what you had before so if
you've got something that is neutral
zero you no longer have
and you have something that was negative
before it zero minus a negative number
is positive and you'll get a burst in
dopamine neurons and there will be what
would be capable of reinforcing ET and
so I just go quite quickly through this
just to say that the somatosensory
cortices in insula are involved in two
acts i I had shown this before they
correlate so the the structural
abnormalities here in this structure in
the somatosensory cards and insula
actually correlates with the severity of
premonitory urges and now to get to the
idea of how this works
computational and then ultimately that
explains how the relation to dopamine is
that here if you exactly as I said we've
terminating the premonitory urge will
lead to a positive prediction error and
what dopamine really what phytic
dopamine represents are positive
prediction heirs and so dopamine would
fire and so the idea here is that if
you're in a state you on the left on
number one turns aside you which is this
urge diversity profundity you go this SR
safe state in which it's neutral it's
zero so zero minus the negative value of
you is the positive prediction air and
that would be were strengthened the tick
so actions can be strengthened not only
by positive things but also by avoiding
or terminating negative things and this
is just a little simulation of how there
would occur and there's a couple of ways
computationally that this occurs but I'm
I want to leave some time for questions
so just to just to stir we can then
integrate these ideas with the
computational models that I had shown
before we can add these parts about the
car
is there negative valves and how that
leads to an increase in dopamine I won't
have time to go through that and I just
wanna sort of terminate now and say that
this is a again a very busy slide but
the idea here is just to show that we've
tried to relate a lot of different
things so dopamine innovation how its
effects on faceook and tonic dopamine
how that relates to having learning in
the execution how happy learning in the
execution are related to thick learning
and execution the role then on the right
the role of the premonitory urges in
then in using dopamine release and so on
and so really yeah he said we have we
think is very very integrity and
cohesive account which in a sense is
going back to the very first slide it's
like building the house or in this case
it's it's a replica of the Parthenon
which I like because the Parthenon has
some mathematically interesting
qualities too so just determinate I'd
like to thank the first who who spent a
lot of this work with me Angelo and
Catalina who are also involved in some
of the tourettes work and Michael with
whom I've discussed a lot of these
models over time and I'll take questions
if there's time thank you so much for
that excellent talk dr. Maya I love the
that was great I appreciate you putting
together those bricks that build the
cosy cohesive future for increased
innovation thank you so now we have time
for a few questions in live Q&A portion
which was right now and if anybody has
any questions please submit them to our
speaker by clicking the ask a question
box on the far left of your screen and
any questions
now we'll be answered by our speaker via
email so we will go to questions here
that says can you speak a little more to
the role of gaba in Tourette syndrome
yes yes of course
yes so that's a great question and I'm
grateful for the question because it
allows me to to say that although I
focused on dopamine and I'm not saying
that dopamine is the end all and be all
of everything in and so gaba is
certainly well first of all the the
circuits in the basal ganglia they're
all GABAergic rightness of gaba clearly
has an interesting and important effect
there and ii really what matters to
large extent is this balance between the
direct and indirect benefits for some a
very old idea but I think it's still
relevant that the balance between the
direct and indirect pathway is where it
all really comes into play and for
example there's evidence that questions
with threads have a reduced number of
fast-spiking inter neurons in the
striatum and these are engineers are
GABAergic and how does that relate to
this whole account well it does because
again the idea is that the balance
between the direct and indirect pathway
softeners and the fast fighting
engineering seems actually thing even
the direct pathway more than they
inhibiting direct path and so if you
have reduced number of fast-spiking
terms you would then have sort of a
relative design emission of the direct
pathway so Mario activity relative to no
go which is kind of same effect that you
have with the way the tonic dopamine and
so whatever leads to that kind of
imbalance could easily lead to the same
the same consequences
I think that's related to another
question that we have about dopamine
acts differently on d1 versus d2
receptors
did you model account for this we're
modeling strengthening cortical becoming
a manic connectivity during the habit
formation yes that's exactly right so so
so the answer is yes we did the whole
world
there's two answers to their in depends
on which part of to talk the question
refers to but in the more detailed part
of talk in confessional in more detailed
part that's exactly what it's all about
is that you have differential effects on
plasticity and on excitability on the
direct versus indirect pathway precisely
because the direct pathway has d1
receptors and the indirect pathway has
d2 receptors and they have opposite
effects so that's what leads to sort of
symmetric effects on plasticity or
reverse effects on plasticity in the two
pathways and reverse effects on
excitability in two pathways it's
exactly because of them so where we did
not do that and that's because we
sometimes only have this very detailed
computational models and it's more
difficult to fit them to actual
empirical data so we did not do that
anyway we use the simple thing was in
the article in which we show the
strengthening in controls of we showed
the Q values and the learning of Q
values and how that evolved over time
there we use a very simple model in
which we just use the single equation
for the strengthening or weakening of
the particles trifle synapse and so we
sort of collapse the two pathways into
one if you will but in the more detailed
account for sure and it's a very
important part of how medications work
white they work the way they work and so
on right because dopamine tends to see
in the cortex at the neck of the
cortical straight Junction yeah that's
exactly right
yeah and it seems in opposite ways in
the direct versus indirect pathway
another question is what are the
circuits that might be interacting or
interfering with double integration
right so well I mean the circuit say in
that model it is actually if you have a
chance to see if you haven't seen the
previous talk by Tony grace he has an
excellent account of the circuits that
modulate for example tonic versus phasic
and how they're different and it's a
fairly complicated but very very elegant
it's actually not it's an elegant sorry
and
the tonic versus phasic crying of
neurons are driven by different neurons
by different receding structures and so
on but I guess the the idea here is that
if you have too much dopamine innovation
we really don't know what is going on
but imagine you just have too many
dopamine terminals it's a very simple
account if you just have too many
dopamine terminals even the the
regulation might be exactly the same but
you just have more terminals sort of
dumping more dopamine out and there will
be enough to explain the whole thing
even if there was no proceeding no
upstream effect driving that so so but
we just don't know if that's the case we
need more detailed studies including
post-mortem studies which have not been
done with definitely with the level of
detail that they should be in the basis
of the development of new machine tools
okay so great question so yes and no
explain what I mean
so the models to a large X well so
there's some reasons to believe that the
direction indirect pathway are useful
it's useful for example to have these
two pathways as opposed to a single
pathway which is what he would do in
machine learning
but for that I defer to the work of
Michael Frank with Ann Collins they have
a nice psychological review article on
this in which they tried to look at well
why would you have these two systems
what are the advantages of having these
two systems and the
that's really their work so the yellow
part in which I did want to mention that
this gives me an opportunity to go back
to something that I mentioned earlier
which is the linking between this theory
this theoretically based computational
psychiatry chai tend to work on and in
the machine learning part and we have
argued quite at length about this in an
article with Quentin - Michael Frank as
well energy neuroscience in two years
ago I think maybe three years ago by now
in which yeah it is one of the big
problems with the machine learning
approach as you will know is that it
requires massive amounts of data and it
deals with the curse of dimensionality
so you have very very high dimensional
data sets and so it's very difficult to
- to do with such high dimensional
excess that's why you need huge very
very big data and and so the techniques
that are used to the dimensionality
reduction that you need to do to them
have classifiers and son things capable
of predicting are usually completely a
theoretical and statistical so you can
do all sorts of ICS or you can do
elastic nets that have embedded
dimensionality reduction you can do all
sorts of things but really it's not a
guided intelligent mechanistic basis of
dimensionality reduction so what the
computational models allow you to do
hopefully if they're good is you can get
specific parameters of computational
models that should represent things that
are ideologically more meaningful that
will represent things such as the extent
to which dopamine is released or the
extent the the size of the prediction
errors and things of that sort and if
indeed from the mechanistic size we
think those are very relevant it might
be that then with those small numbers of
parameters from computational models
rather than the Roth IRA which is you
know hundreds of thousands of variables
you can run those computational models
extract some key parameters and
then the dimensionality reduction is
done for you you can apply a machine
learning on the small set of parameters
and like I said it's a long story
there's a couple of examples on of this
they have been published when I actually
also from Michael Frank's lab we're
working on one that we hope to submit
relatively soon too but it's one of the
ideas using these models which have
specific parameters they can fit to
direct to do here the dimensionality
reduction and then the Machine momentos
thank you very very much we are
absolutely out of time but it was
exciting and very interesting thank you
Michael oh yeah
we invite our attendees join us again in
an hour from now at 10:00 a.m. Pacific
time 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time as we
continue the discussion of computational
psychiatry with dr. winter shipping he
will be presenting identifying pattern
transitions of mind and brain in
psychotherapy the nonlinear dynamics of
human change processes I hope to see you
there